good morning Millennials
good morning Millennials I just realized
I stopped with my hair in a braid what
does it look like crazy no it looks like
a little unkempt chipping it back into
the low bun yeah yeah it's a little it's
feeling like miss Frizzle it's a little
puffy yeah that's what it's been is this
this summer for the first time
experiencing like what it means to have
Jewish puffy hair because like something
changing its hair maybe he's like
getting older his hair is so puffy like
he can't leave the house of that
literally looking like he got a perm no
but it's always been tough you remember
that time when we were gambling and I
crazy yeah but like that was bedhead
that wasn't like humid humidity like
poofiness who knows there's so much to
discuss today I am back in New York from
the Kentucky royal wedding we went to
pride yesterday taylor swift's is taking
on the music industry literally on her
back and there's just so much to break
down so much to discuss so much to
gossip over that I truly am gonna like
have a burden on my shoulders until we
talk about it all Jenny look I woke up
this morning being like wow there's a
lot to discuss
there's a lot to discuss and it's not
yet tan to the past five stories no it's
not
we have so much catching up to do so
much catching up what a long weekend so
much happened you were in Kentucky for a
week we were also in Minneapolis Margot
like does not feel like six years ago
I just say Minneapolis toasters our top
five for me
really they [ __ ] showed up when I
needed them I played my first Comedy
Festival like people from the festival
were there being like who the [ __ ] is
this fat [ __ ] and like the toasters
just I got a standing ovation before I
even started like I just love the
toaster so much that is so nice I do
love Minnesota and those Minnesota
summer Jackie we experienced the
Minnesota summers and they're [ __ ]
brutal they're so hot yeah oh my god
Kentucky like I can't even talk about I
I don't forget show that I live in
Kentucky now because I've been there for
actually seven days
partially by myself which was really
lonely and partially with Ben which was
just as only because he was on his phone
the whole time because there was like a
whole free-agent
thing going on yesterday and he was
trying to compare how Kevin Durant going
to the Nets is similar to Scott
Borchetta selling Taylor's show's music
catalog to Scooter Braun which made no
sense but if you are into sports or you
just like you know the discussions
free agents Ben and his friends are
recording a new episode of the Schmidt's
tonight going in on Kevin Durant Kyrie
Irving the nets of it all oh hi Leonard
so look out for that the schvitz it'll
be probably coming out tomorrow at 3
o'clock like always yeah crazy times um
we saw Hugh Jackman this weekend oh yeah
wow so much didn't happen i speaker know
so much happened this week I'm like it
was NWO and then and sneetches had NWO
and pride and it was really fun again
Hugh Jackman was amazing me too and I
was enjoying it there and then I watched
my stories back the next day and I was
like I want to go again like it was so
good I've heard rave reviews it was just
it was so good it's not every day that
you see if 50 year old man tap-dancing
at Madison Square Garden a 50 year old
straight man it's just like allegedly
anytime you just see a chorus line of
tap dancers at Madison Square Garden
like it was really nice true showbiz
like as it was in Dallas theatrical it
was like Broadway and it was really it
was a treat did you get drunk I didn't
drink but I didn't know I haven't I
didn't I just been trying to drink not
at all just ringing at home no just like
drinking not drinking when I don't need
to drink like I didn't just yesterday I
pried and I'm just like tired of being
tired I'm sick and tired of being sick
I'm definitely tired of like drinking
outside like being in pull like sticky
restaurants on chairs that hurt my back
with like I think there's an underrated
activity and drinking at home oh for
sure but like when I'm at home that's
when it's like you know how people say I
don't need to drink to have fun yeah I
don't need to drink to be home well I've
been discovering all these sorts of wine
I'm turning into a little bit of an why
now people have been calling me Amy
Winehouse and the summer is the best way
to discover new wines you're guaranteed
to love with first leaf the wine club
that lets you use your feedback to
curate wine selections to your unique
tastes whether you're entertaining
company or enjoying a warm summer night
at home first leaf makes buying great
wine easy by rating the ones who receive
first leaf determines your likes and
dislikes and they only send ones you
love I started by taking the first leaf
wine quiz to assess our exact wine
drinking preferences from sweetness to
styles to red to white we love a quiz
over here it's just it makes me feel
seen it makes me feel heard
sign up with our link and you'll get an
exclusive intro offer six bottles of
wine for only 29
95 plus free shipping just go to try
first leaf dot-com slash toast that six
bottles of wine for only twenty nine
ninety five plus free shipping at try
first leaf calm slash toast
we got a bottles about a week ago about
a week ago a a and it's been really
premium anything delivered to my door
especially alcohol I can get on board
with so this was a very easy partnership
very easy partner
anything with a quiz anything with a
quiz like truly also I'm not pregnant
for those of you speculating if you saw
me ripping and Julie yesterday you would
think do people think you're pregnant
because they just said I'm not drinking
but like you guys really nor we that
like barbaric that we're either drinking
or pregnant no it's so crazy like the
and I don't know when like speculating
that someone was pregnant like became an
insult but like it's definitely an
insult it would say who are you you know
ready I got the most insane comment on
my picture from pride yesterday I hate
even give it air but it was so stupid
that I have to talk about it it was like
referring to my outfit or something and
they're like no shade but this is much
better than your outfit to the wedding
I'm like okay but you just said
something mean and that is shade it's
like you're you're not very smart
because you're literally saying the
opposite of what you're saying do you
don't mean like no shade but here's
something shady so you're gonna be mean
and leave a comment on my picture you
have to be smart you know that's the
only rule which is really hard for
people who leave me in comments cuz
that's like the one thing they're not
capable of doing but I just felt like I
was really annoyed at the lack of
intelligence in that comment and it
pissed me off
yeah like my dress the wedding like [ __ ]
you I look absolutely amazing
apples and oranges my friends right what
are you talking about a my pride like
what it was yesterday
keep up pay attention please um
counselor snitch you put your mic on yes
I was bought I show you who she gotta
get my attention
imagine if she went this whole episode
without a mic ejido passion and Laura
wanted us to put a trigger warning on
this episode because she's about to be
triggered I'm about to be triggered by
my sister Jackie I know it I feel like
coming I feel it coming too and I
actually feel like I am really in the
middle actually I here's the thing I
think that I'm the world burn details
but you know we referring to the Taylor
Swift saga and the world's scale I'm in
the middle and in the scene II scale you
are in the middle because I'm in the
middle and now you're in the
middle of the middle and Taylor you know
I mean the middle of you two yeah but
like she's firmly Taylor I'm the middle
I'm like having no horse in this race
and your middle Taylor okay we're gonna
talk about it we're gonna break it all
down because like I literally couldn't
sleep I was feeling so devastated and
heartbroken about like what's going on
in the world of music industry um and
all I can say is good morning to have
around except for Scott Borchetta yeah
and that's yeah I had to say this
morning he was missing I think I think
that's a good place to start oh boy wait
can we also talk about how this morning
we found out that Joe Jonas calls the on
Instagram he was gonna send up a wedding
gift I think that the oh [ __ ] like could
be rude if he did it yeah um so I think
he just is a big fan of premium content
you know and either Sidhu he respects
the hustle let's see uh puts in like CEO
had a big weekend he was like really
thirsting out all weekend you know when
like loggers I get dressed up and do a
bunch of outfits her photo she's like
mother like son we were both thirsting
out all weekend no totally and it paid
off cuz like he was just being premium
his flowers popping and I just love him
how was your nut for you was weekend out
even though Jackie can only get halfway
through and she dumped him at the edge
at Margot's okay I do not got him yeah I
was happy I'm happy to take him and I
had him two nights which is what I was
supposed to have originally but then you
guys added another night because Ben
wanted to go out with his friends what
yeah I was supposed to get him on Friday
cuz been left on yeah yeah I got him on
Thursday but why because I saw him Ben's
story he was like out keto seasoning
eating tuna with mercury poisoning what
oh my god that's the worst part of what
you just told me I'm gonna kill him you
know they need to send his mercury
levels to the State Department because
it was so high that they had to alert
the government I mean [ __ ] bed is
sitting over here eating tuna salad I'm
gonna kill him if anyone like I'm if
anyone's gonna have mercury poisoning
like it should be in like where one eats
more fish in that man so oh my god I'm
furious I'm gonna kill him anyway so I
did have two nights with him and we by
Saturday likes Mitch did really want him
and we had exhausted all options of
sleeping arrangements at my house
without like you know driving Zack to
the couch no he went to the couch next
was the hotel so you got it but we had a
really fun day we had such a fun day
like aunt uncle and nephew we took him
to the Seaport like he had five-star
cuisine a Sean George
and like he said that the pup tartare
Wow Nina you guys are just such
different like babysitters you know what
I mean like you like are out and about
all the time but you're also
all the time you like feel welcome you
out of like so survive my Mario wasn't
me her house but Theo doesn't bother her
you know I didn't I'd never caught these
hanky looking you were just like you had
lots of concerns you know yeah cuz I'm
concerned about your child I'm sorry
this is the thing the key to being a dog
mom is just like they're fine you know
it's like I used to every time I sit on
the couch with the open to be walking
around around me I would have to like
watch him until he sits down like he's
fine you know just like whatever he's
alive that's what matters but did you
die no for now anyways it was a great
weekend but I think it's time oh do you
I do because it's like we're all just
we're doing the journey the elephant in
the room okay and I think it's time to
deliver actually I know it's time to
deliver in the past five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
okay everyone's worried that we're not
gonna recap Jackson Brittany's wedding
and pride and like you guys gird your
loins it's [ __ ] 11:00 10:42 like we
have over an hour don't worry okay but
I'm getting ready cuz I'm going into the
ring with counselors Mitch anyways the
way that I've decided to report on this
story is to read everyone's statement
word for word okay
oh my god that's gonna take us forever
no but it's important it's important
okay
first up it all started yesterday
morning's the Wall Street Journal June
30th when Taylor Swift posted to
Instagram story with a swipe up linked
to her tumblr page the tumblr post said
she's a blogger now by the way she's
always been logger for years I asked
pleaded for a chance to own my work
instead I was given the opportunity to
sign back up to Big Machine Records and
quote earned one album at a time one for
every new one I turned in I walked away
because I knew once I sign that contract
stop or shadow would sell the label
thereby selling me in my future I had to
make the excruciating choice to leave
behind my past music I wrote on my
bedroom floor and videos I dreamed up
and paid for from the money I earned in
bars and clubs then arenas and stadiums
some fun facts about today's news I
learned about scooter bronze purchase of
my masters as it was announced to the
world all I could think about was the
incessant manipulative bullying I'd
receive
his hands for years like when Kim
Kardashian orchestrated an illegally
recorded snippet of a phone call to be
leaked and then scooter got his two
clients together to bull me bully me
online about it see photo the photo is a
FaceTime of Justin Bieber facetiming
with Kanye scooter and a man in the
middle saying caption Taylor Swift what
up on his Instagram where when his
client Kanye West organized a revenge
porn music video which strips my body
naked now scooters shoot me of my life's
work that I wasn't given an opportunity
to buy essentially my musical legacy is
about to lie in the hands of someone who
tried to dismantle it this is my worst
case scenario this is what happens when
you sign the deal at 15 to someone who
for who for who the term loyalty is
clearly just a contractual concept and
when that man says music has value he
means its value is beholden to men who
had no part in creating it when I left
my masters in Scotts hands I made peace
with the fact that eventually he would
sell them never in my worst nightmares
did I imagine the buyer would be scooter
anytime Scott Borchetta has heard the
word Scooter Braun escape my lips it was
when I was either crying or trying not
to he knew what he was doing they both
did controlling a woman who didn't want
to be associated with them in perpetuity
that means forever thankfully I'm now
signed to a label that believes I should
own anything I create thankfully I left
my past in Scotts hands and not my
future and hopefully young artists are
kids with musical dreams will read this
and learn about how to better protect
themselves in the negotiation you
deserve to own the art you make I will
always be proud of my past work but for
a healthier option lever will be out
August 23rd I mean if anything this is
just like so much incentive for her to
release like ten albums right now like
maybe the alteril extended version that
like definitely exists that we don't
have yet like it's that well that way
she could own it you know or just really
record did brand new out of the woods
like the tour version so badly definite
better man done so she's making a lot of
claims yes she's making a lot of funds
first of all that Scooter Braun has been
bullying her second of all that Scott
Borchetta like sold her like her life's
work out from under her like not giving
her the opportunity to buy it she
continued to buy it outright just to
Ernie she also said that she did not
know about the news until it broke with
everyone else and she also more most
importantly said she offered many times
and tried to figure out a way for her to
buy the masters but was brutally
rebuffed brutally removed okay so when
you first read this and I read this
answer I was like wow this is really sad
no this is remember that movie 50 feet
from stardom yeah
about the backup singer who like just
couldn't get out of a contract and like
she really was meant to be like the next
Aretha Franklin but because of the
contracts like it was just like one of
those stories where it's like what's
that thing where it's like Phil Spector
is that it we use like whatever like
it's just like one of those horrible
things where like you have to owe dr.
Luke like you have to work with your
with your resume yeah yeah yeah and when
I first read it like I've always really
liked Scooter Braun just heard him afar
no stay respected him so this was
actually another you know cross to bear
it's like a Kim Taylor situation where
it's like wow two people that I respect
and I enjoy don't agree with each other
one has to be wrong and one has to be
right yeah and it was hard for me to
even take a firm stance like as much as
I wanted to support Taylor because I was
like I feel as though scooters kind of
not a bad guy right now there was like
this narrative that in in her tone and
all the people who spoke out afterwards
like that yeah everyone knows scooters a
bad guy I'm like oh do they cuz I didn't
know that no I ain't I've heard that
he's I always liked him up until this
whole thing happened buddy slimy in the
way that how he forced Justin Bieber
continued on the purpose world tour when
he didn't he literally was having a
mental breakdown but then he stopped and
he forced ariana grande to put ghosting
on her album I've heard that to most
personal said today what if you know
that it's probably not true maybe but I
think that there's a reason why everyone
quickly out like Beyonce and then like
unfollowing there's all these hammers
that like Rihanna unfollowed Harry
Styles unfollowed I don't know if that's
where are we hearing this these facts
because how do we know we they never
followed them in the beginning
I'm sorry stands like honestly keep
track okay so now everyone is speaking
out Justin Bieber posted something that
uh you know he's escalated the entire
thing yeah well no he was defending
scooter who's obviously his friend um he
just he first apologized for that post
to begin with which is a mature thing to
do he was like it was stupid scooter
actually advised me not to post it
whatever and that scooter is a good guy
he's never had anything but respect for
you but no his his post was starting off
being an apology and then quickly became
like more of an attack yeah just a
defensive scooter yeah whereas like it
was like I'm sorry but like that doesn't
always count and I feel like this entire
situation is really
knowingly like misdirected like why is
nobody talking about the evil that is
Scott Borchetta that's where I feel like
I'm I'm a Taylor apologist always and
forever stand till I die
but I really feel like and she knows
when she says something like the
followers will be gas lit and let the
[ __ ] up and giving death threats and all
that [ __ ] because we live in the most
[ __ ] up world's ever but I really feel
like the target of her of her attack
really should have been Scott Borchetta
Scooter Braun doesn't Oh Taylor script
anything they don't know each other
they've never worked together like he's
just a random buyer in my eyes but Scott
Borchetta created Taylor Swift's global
bread alongside her Scott Borchetta was
a freak with an afro until Taylor Swift
gave him a platform like he's just as
much in debt to her as she is to him he
made her and she made him so this
betrayal for me is so on Scott Borchetta
's brain like I can't even begin and I
wish you would direct half of the anger
she has towards scooter towards Scott
because the way that okay I can't even
talk about the Kanye Kim Taylor thing
because it's the one thing that I just I
don't want to talk about like I just
can't but she keeps talking about it
it's like I know what I'm saying she
keeps blaming Scooter Braun for things
that Kanye West and Justin Bieber did
know and she like he's a god okay their
manager the Kim and Kanye thing happened
she took a year off she put out a whole
album about it took another year off she
year-and-a-half up she's putting out
another album and she's still the one
who keeps on going back to it when it's
like we're all moving on with you like
we all want to forget it and you keep
reminding us and by the way like it was
your least slathering moment that you
keep reminding us about it's like she
keeps saying she's moved on she turned
the snake into a thing she can laugh out
in arenas and she's gotten over it she
has not gotten over it no she has not
gotten oh and now she's blaming sweeter
and I really I want to read the Isles
post because I think it's important
scooters wife posted and then deleted an
Instagram notes screenshot when I was
backtracking pertinent to the situation
why she'd leave it archived it so it's
like that but it doesn't come up on
feeds anymore it's back in the biz okay
good because I think it's pertinent I've
never been one for a public airing of
laundry but when you attack my husband
here we go let's start with Taylor Swift
whoa then let's get the facts straight
you were given the opportunity
to own your masters he passed in we can
I pause mm-hmm I just think everyone is
giving like their own statements that
are so one-sided like yes Taylor ship
was offered when when she was shopping
around her new record label big big
machine made her an offer and the offer
was basically you continue to stay with
us and we'll sell you back your albums
with each new one you give us basically
you can run if that okay that's what she
said but Scott Borchetta said something
else
no no he's he's one gauge of like
probably a 50 page contract just to
support his his side like everyone is
being so one guy said it did not say one
thing that contradicted anything that
Taylor said he said like he gave her the
opportunity to get them back but not in
an album for album sort of way because
that's not how concerts are gonna work
anymore okay but Taylor said that that's
a hard two percent how they phrased it
that she had to earn it back and ask
opera shadow released one page like
literally with two paragraphs of an
entire contract to me that doesn't prove
anything that just proves that if you
want to see if you want to be proof give
me the whole thing
I want the entire contract all my
lawyers go over it okay you were given
an opportunity to own your master as you
passed interesting that the man you're
so quote grossed out by believed in you
more than you believe in yourself your
dad is on the board and was notified and
were shed up personally told you before
this came out so no you didn't find out
what the world and girl who are you to
talk about bullying the world has
watched you collect and drop friends
like wilted flowers my husband is
anything but a bully but he spent his
intent his life standing up for people
and causes he believes in Scott scooter
was so excited to bill to work and build
with you how embarrassing this temper
tantrum is because you didn't get your
way he believes in and supports you I
sincerely hope you can learn to love and
believe in yourself the way my husband
does lastly if you think he can control
his clients please control your fans
leave our personal life and kids out of
this you don't understand yet what line
that crosses but one day you will and I
hope you have the dignity class and
kindness to leave your fans out of this
and have an open discussion
tumblr can't fix this a phone call can
wait there's one more slide in her post
about the Kim Kanye thing that I just
thought no there's not an end yes there
is
yes beyond that it's easy to see that
the point of putting this out was to get
people to bully him you were supposed to
be a role model but continued to model
bullying he's a manager not God he
cannot control the actions of other
humans even ones he manages don't blame
him because
Kim caught you in a lie it's
embarrassing I know but adults own up to
their mistakes we learn and grow from
them we don't divert blame and blur the
lines of reality to suit our needs what
you haven't seen is what happens behind
closed doors when he is supported and
stood up for you when he has challenged
his clients to be kinder be quiet when
he has reached out when he has reached
an olive branch out to you on numerous
occasions okay I don't necessarily
believe that like Sheena bran is like
the tailor should have number-one fan
behind the scenes like making all these
things happen for her like I don't think
he really cares about her that were true
then then dealer wouldn't be doing this
like that makes absolutely understand
but I'm just first of all I don't like
there's one thing I don't like in that
that was very well said she made her
point I just don't like that she
referred to it as a temper tantrum
because she didn't get her right like if
at the end of the day all Taylor wants
is to own the work that she created like
that's not a temper tantrum like that's
fair yeah I mean no I wasn't by that
it's temper tantrums it's hurtful like
literally her leg the back whistle she
can be obsessive the fact that the music
industry doesn't work like that is
[ __ ] up and that's what Taylor's like
mission in life has been like give
artists the the credit they deserve the
percentage in like the Spotify streaming
like that's always been her platform so
this is very on brand first I just don't
like that it's being referred to it's
like her being a [ __ ] like throwing a
temper tantrum because she was you know
put out by Kim and Kanye five years
that's what she wrote like she didn't
write artists don't have a say abysus
system is [ __ ] bah bah bah she could
have written that essay and said she
wrote scooters been bullying me he was
unconscious I'd like she made it Petty
and personal when it could have been
just an abstract thing about why didn't
I get the chance to pony up three
hundred million dollars and buy my own
okay she couldn't afford it and I also
want to say and I know you disagree with
me it's like this happens in the music
there's that she's by far the biggest
artist at big machine but this happens
in the music entry this happens in the
world people by companies you've got
bought by a company that you don't want
to work for a blah blah but like this is
just business like everyone it's part of
being an artist someone else is like
she's she's trying to change business
and then she's not changing business
with her petty bringing it back to Kim
and Kanye that I could shoot nothing
with that and I also won that was what I
wanted to say here today all of this is
being misdirected because of what she
said
100% I don't I agree with everything
Taylor stands for and what the point was
but I do I think the way in which she
went about arguing this made no sense
like she should've just spoken about how
she [ __ ] on her masters because that's
what art that's what the music industry
should be in that but she's working
towards like making it about drama from
five years ago like it's pointless to me
and that is what turned it into this
[ __ ] show
no and it's just like when she does
things like this when yes in hindsight
she should have said it differently but
you know she spent out like so much time
crafting this she is very meticulous so
it's like this was what she wanted to
put out there like she's still so petty
and like I'm like you think she's come
so far you've like read like her 34:30
thing an L and like she seems mature and
over it and she like she took away like
life lessons from that situation with
Kim and Kanye but then like she just
goes back to that like girl who's just
not mature you know I didn't want to
talk about this fair reason we have to
talk about item there out a long time no
I literally can't because you want to
know why like I paint it literally I'm
gonna stab myself it pains me to say
Jackie's making some excellent points
the Backstairs
because no for all this growth that
Taylor has had and I really like believe
in her and there is so much growth like
what is you doing like I have no I mean
there's the point is is that it's crap
or satis fault and that that's she
didn't say that either she did but she
explains herself she rarely writes an
essay where she explains herself and
give like she's always with her clues
and her findings and take take from it
what you will but she literally sat down
and told us what to think and she didn't
harp on the right things she just went
back to the dumb [ __ ] no and it's like
the people around Taylor are the ones
defending her most and really making the
most articulate points like Martha Hahn
said like you deserve to own the art you
create like we live in this [ __ ] up
world especially the music industry
where like these random thoughts
literally five white dudes in the world
own like all the music of people like
and and that's the real point here and
it's like everyone around her is making
these poignant points about you know
about the music industry about what
artists
should own and it's like her her
response was just like it was a bit of a
letdown for me I agree and I thought
salsa
yeah else piece was very well said and
also it really does agree i think hers
was as petty as taylor's no I can she
dress
Taylor's petit points therefore she's
talking petty and her bringin I brought
who people pretend to take like a moral
high ground over something like you're
being Petty and but I'm gonna be petty
and pretend I'm better than you like
that I don't you know who's not saying
you're being petty and I'm gonna take a
moral high ground but I'm also than me
petty it's scooter Bruntlett phone
nothing Oh Scooter Braun that said
nothing except through proxies of Justin
Bieber obtained Nevada he's like that's
our Scooter Braun and I like out out and
I love Taylor like what am I gonna say
yeah I act like this is the Today Show
but whatever yeah no it is that it is I
can't I really like this is upsetting
and I'm mad at everyone okay um
I they I understand why my being put in
this position I just want to enjoy music
I know and that's like what's really
frustrating but then I also have to
think there's so many artists be as big
as Taylor Adele Beyonce etc and what
Britta Lori's like why Thomas's masters
right what's that process like yeah does
she I don't know so but now they're with
jay-z fine Adele I don't know but I
think Taylor got buff because she made
the record deal so young that she didn't
know so maybe like most people own their
renegotiate like maybe a child isn't on
her first album right but after its
success she went to go like but Taylor
had signed on to a six-album contract so
she had no choice I think and I just
want to give an honorable mention to
Kacey Musgraves because no I don't I
don't like that it's fishy dude I'm like
so she had like yeah I suppose egg has
nothing to do with that she has a song
called good ol boys club that has the
shadiest lair any part of a big machine
don't sound like fun to me don't wanna
be part
the good ol boys club should I predicted
that she's the soothsayer yeah it was
like a shady lyric towards Big Machine
Records which had the time people
thought was like shady towards Taylor
but now it's part of the big machine
yeah and the good old boys club which is
exactly what this is and I'm not
convinced that Scooter Braun is the
devil though no me neither and I never
was but people are really trying to like
peanut that way like fine like it's like
him next and maybe it's just like the
the Jew in me but everyone like coming
for scooter like calling him the word
slimy like that has anti-semitic
undertone I'm sorry only concerned with
his wealth and his ego I don't like that
oh I didn't see that
todrick's post was like giving me like
anti-semitic no come on Tom Lauren I'm
gonna be like slimy slimy slimy like for
some really greedy greedy - money money
money the word slimy like it definitely
has anti-semitic Tropes well I just used
it so I guess I'm anti-semitic I think
you are my girl and you know what for
that reason if I like the narrative that
he only cares about money like I'm sorry
if you work in the music industry but
Scott Borchetta only caring about my
needs okay no one said that yet anyone
with a job only cares about money no
totally but like no one says Scott
Borchetta he cares about money like but
they but he's he's the one who just sold
it he's the one who got three under
million I'm just peeling if anything my
shirt or cares not art I'm just feeling
a lot of pressure because I just feel
like it's like the resonant Taylor sound
like I have to deny and I mean I'm just
like I apologize you know what I
literally can't talk that's it
I just I love Taylor more than anything
in this world and I ride her die for her
till the day I die like I will be going
to her concerts when I'm 80 but I just
wish she knew we had to talk about it
people are turning to us cuz people
don't like people just because I'm
feeling the same way like I just never
get along yeah nobody wants nobody wants
to start sure yeah we need to Angie
Cohen right now to host a reunion and we
just air it all out this season
everything sort of position as the Kim
tells yeah solution where it's like I
love both and I and I don't want to take
a side yeah so I'm not gonna I'm not
taking sides but I'm just saying like I
feel bad for the Brown family I think
they had a hard day yesterday a meteo I
think Taylor had a hard day - yes
everyone had a bad day except Scott
Borchetta and him
and his annoying [ __ ] Instagram
comments like he left a comment on
scooters Instagram like announcing the
lib murder me like I'm even more excited
about this after today like stop or
shadows like the nerd who finally gets
like accepted into the cool crew and
like sells his soul just like oh I can
walk to remember that kid who like
literally broke his neck jumping off the
thing just to be with the cool kids like
that's got porchetta I don't [ __ ] with
Scott Borchetta like that's my only
qualm of today right and like it could
have been about with Scott Borchetta but
she needed about scooter I know she mind
about Kim yeah and that's why we're
talking about them also her saying that
scooter has been bullying her really
[ __ ] bother me because posting a
picture and saying Taylor Swift what up
I don't think his bullying it's like
when housewives when people disagree
with them they're like you're all
bullying me and it's like no you're
being an [ __ ] so like I think the
word bullying is so overused in her
saying that Scooter Braun has I don't
know what's aside from what she says
goes on behind the scenes what we've
seen which is him and Instagram with
Justin Bieber saying Taylor so what up
like yeah that's like shady and stupid
but it's not like bullying do you know
what I mean um no I mean I think that
she's take like that instance like
scooter brought as a manager like you
shouldn't be involved and [ __ ] like that
and that whole Taylor Swift what I'm
thinking like that was mean and that was
maybe not bullying but it was like
bandwagon ganging up like when the whole
world is turning to Taylor like Justin
Bieber and some manager to like it was
just really unnecessary and that was
like the only point she really made that
I think that I agreed with but she just
took it so far took like that one thing
like he deleted the caption he was
[ __ ] 18 like who cares but I don't
know I just like I really won't talk
about anyone okay but like I'm just
looking at this picture of the FaceTime
and now I'm starting to think logistics
cuz scooters holding the phone so it
looks like scooter and Justin were
facetiming this must have been the day
after or like right around when all the
drama was happening and Kanye happens to
be in the room so he pops in like hey
Justin Justin takes the screenshot and
then he posts that Taylor Swift what up
like what part did scooter that no
that's what y'all saying he's not God
and that's what I say as well it's like
why are we blaming
scooter for what his clients do scooter
has 7,000 clients one of them being
Karlie Kloss right like it technically
if we were doing that we could blame
Taylor like Scott Borchetta for what
Taylor does right no it's just that
Carly
it all can someone I don't know I can't
cancer made one comment so I think that
she is excluding herself from this thing
yeah L and scooter were at her wedding
one week ago Taylor was not scooter
manages her yes it has for a really long
time but they can't all be best friends
like scootering I can't be best friends
with Carly at Carly's best times at Tim
now especially and Hearn Carly
definitely took some time off but Carly
mental reputation tour nashville like
they got back together for a minute like
i don't know what's going on there but
that was for a year no i feel as though
they might not be sort of Yael said you
drop friends like wilted flowers she's
talking about Carly oh I thought she was
just talking about you know the girls go
ahead wad who was who's in who's out
right alveta then but maybe she's
talking about Carly and she knows the
team she definitely knows to say that's
you know like just okay for me I need
everyone to get along so in order to
wrap this up I'm we're gonna do it on
the positive note if Taylor was watching
what would you say you're better than
this like you're really you're you are
literally you have the potential to be
like the greatest artist of our
generation like both from a business
standpoint and from a creative
standpoint like act like it like just
get off your phone like just write music
like you are so much better and more
than this and you don't need to be in
the swamp on tumblr like with your fans
like [ __ ] yelling at people like just
rise above in the words of Michelle
Obama when they go low Taylor we go high
but I do I do
appreciate her shining a light on this
music industry that is really so [ __ ]
up that like you could spend ten years
working on something and then someone
else you can own it your worst enemy
whether that's uh validate like true or
not could own anyone could own it except
for you and then you have happened to
Jojo she didn't own any of her music but
Jojo had one good song when she was 12
and she recorded and reapin it out
because she could not get behind those
she could not get her [ __ ] so this is
like so now with nobody cared him
happened to Jojo but now maybe Taylor
well she has she's proven herself she's
actually able to like affect change in
the music and hear the new label that
she signed with one of the terms of her
contract was all signed with you as long
as you
structure your entire like streaming
whatever with with your clients now
everyone who works at that label got to
benefit every artist got like Nicki
Minaj got to benefit from Taylor signing
there so she really is the best of
intentions hmm yeah she just needs a
better um method and isn't that all of
our greatest John Falls my dad is my
life's issue it's like I'm a I have good
points and then I'm such an animal beast
to get to that point then I lose all
credibility yes which is a fair excuse
for you but knowing how meticulous and
thoughtful she is you can't actually use
that excuse on her because she is
absolutely she woke up yesterday morning
and like didn't think and just broke
because it happened so fast
so I maybe she didn't think and wrote it
but then she thought she doesn't put
anything out without thinking about it
she sent it to people people said yes
like I I agree it was a stream of
conscious but like then she definitely
thought about it she's so filtered
things don't just like slip out of her
she definitely has like some
password-protected [ __ ] you know right
like are you sure you want to send this
tumblr post Taylor yeah think about it
from the morning toast point of view but
I think being a true fan also knowing
when to call people out like I have to
say some some of the best I don't like
with just when people kiss our ass like
when I say something roman polanski is
not a great guy i expect to be called
out on it in a respectful way so there's
a way of being a fan of someone's with
not having to agree with everything they
do but to articulate it in a respectful
way yeah it's just been a really hard
day I know but I'm glad we got through
it I think at the end of the day I hope
whatever this just goes away because
it's annoying but I hope Taylor got your
[ __ ] masters right this might shine
such a spotlight on it that scooter will
say I will sell your masters for cost
whatever they I think what happens next
will be very interesting and I think in
in the name in the sake of of you know
kind of saving his reputation I do think
scooter will be child and offered it
sell her masters at a very reasonable
price or like own them together some
joint venture just because I think like
when he walked up yesterday and like
everyone in the world just agreed that
he was a piece of [ __ ] like out of
nowhere it's like everyone was saying it
as if it was fact and everyone's known
that for years I'm like I'm very
well-versed of pop culture I consider
myself to be a staple of Hollywood
industry and
that no and so I think that was
partially her like prerogative was that
like maybe nothing was happening behind
closed doors so she was like I'm gonna
put your back against the wall publicly
so that you sell me my masters which
could be what you want to do all then
that's weird and calculate I think he's
a really good manager and I think he
would do good things for like I think
they said she should squash it
maybe she to use him I think maybe
there's been resentment between the two
of them forever because scooter is known
for representing everyone at anyone and
if you're if you're legit you're with
scooter and Taylor never wanted to be a
part of like the the Hollywood and crab
like she's very much as her own whatever
so maybe there was resentment there I
don't know I can't I don't know I really
would love to represent her yeah that's
what I'm saying and she wasn't
interested right but so then her what
she said that can't be it because that
wouldn't fit that doesn't track okay
that's what so many shows have been
saying is anyone noticed and watch all
of these shows now and the characters
say that tracks literally I've heard on
Jessica Jones I heard it on crazy
ex-girlfriend I heard it on [ __ ]
something else I'm like is this what
we're saying now did anyone else realize
this let me know I thought I didn't know
it's like that make sense or like that
adds up that tracks you know what that
doesn't track yeah no I just I'm the
more thing about it the more I'm really
upset at the misdirection of anger
because now that I think about it like
really Scott Borchetta is piece of [ __ ]
oh for sure but I thought we all knew
that you know what it's like why is it
Souter Braun's fault or just making a
good business deal like Scott Borchetta
must have known there would be some sort
of ramifications especially from Taylor
like someone just Aires robbed me a
picture of a couple milkshakes except ya
know getting high like she could have
written this thing and not had suitors
Neiman at once it could have been a
Scott Borchetta stole my music like
never let me a gave me the opportunity
to purchase them let me know right and
like now my my all of my life's work is
in the hands of someone that you know I
wouldn't that I don't know where yeah
that's not me I feel like we've beat
this dead horse like I'm ready there's a
lot of other things to cover okay
counselor snitch
love you all no I think we're a good
were mistake oh yeah because exactly
like I you couldn't work
and murder someone and you would come
out right I think I have been very
tempered you guys because first of all
you're always like double teaming me and
it's like you don't even have to come up
with an argument Azir like Taylor Taylor
Taylor Taylor Taylor and like now I have
to here like do my homework well she he
invited her to one love Manchester and
she did not perform so that was [ __ ]
up that he mentioned that by the way
yeah cuz I'm sure she I'm sure she
donated a ton of money and I just I
think that that was also when she was in
hiding so like she just like wasn't
doing it so like that was [ __ ] up that
was a low blow Scott Borchetta
right yeah because when I read that I
was like okay out of context that looks
bad but that's not what there's no way
she just was like she declined right
Yeah right so anyway once again Scott
Borchetta piece oh [ __ ] piece o [ __ ]
everyone moving on Tory one more thing
to say this is the saddest part of the
whole thing Rascal Flatts is part of Big
Machine no that's great Rascal Flatts
should be managed by Scooter Braun like
that's true you can now Scooter Braun oh
that's true okay this meant that there
Scott Borchetta as well and now Florida
Georgia line is there a big machine to
interest I think it's I think it'll be
great
eleven eleven make a wish I wish that
everyone works it out and that's look
what you made me do I can't
we're pulling apart families okay oh she
gave Arianna her plane for Manchester
say I mean yes so that like [ __ ]
summer shout out with the lies the lies
right it's like everyone is releasing
statements with half-truths that only
benefit their side and like that's
what's so annoying and that's why I feel
so conflicted it's like I would very
much like the whole truth and nothing
but the truth so help me God and we'll
never get that the prop because everyone
has their different versions of the way
but everyone has restraints it like
Taylor has the way she saw that picture
on Instagram scooter has the way he was
in that FaceTime and probably like was
like guys according to n like know like
where you know maybe he on that call we
don't know what was said maybe they
wanted to talk [ __ ] and scooter was like
no we're not talking about this and
Justin Bieber took the picture and
posted it I don't think like scooter
said no and we're guys they're they're
experiencing the way that it happened so
there is no hundred percent there's four
sides to this story
Taylor's
scooters and the truth yeah we will
never get this one so let's just let
bygones be bygones no you have to use
all three to like piece together what
you what you kind well my head doesn't
take oceans out of it I can't do that
like because if her emotions are just
that Justin Bieber post in the Kim Kanye
thing and now scooters her worst
nightmare like next up vanderbrook
worldstar Jax Taylor and Britney
Cartwright married in a beautiful
Kentucky wedding and girl with no job
was there as the guest of honor I was
there as the toast correspondent the
toast respondent and as a guest and it
was just really oh my god excuse me a
beautiful weekend really filled with
love Kentucky is warm as [ __ ] I didn't
get any fried chicken so I feel like it
was a total waste of time um but it was
really fun I got to hang out with pretty
much everyone there was lots of downtime
they were filming I might be in the
background like busted it down who knows
God willing and I'm just really excited
to see how they edit stuff you know yes
Tom Schwartz gave what was the longest
and the worst toast ever
I'm sure they'll make it like crickets
long like playing it over eat yeah make
it seem long and [ __ ] Brittany's dad
is the most precious gem of a man I've
loved him since the dam and him which
was yesterday and something really
interesting that I can't wait to see how
they talk how they edit so Brittany I
mean I was at cocktail hour Brittany's
dad came up to me and then he was like
were you guys and we're like I were
friends of Jack's Brittany and he was so
nice he was just talking about how you
know at first when Brittany called him
it was like I'm dating someone somewhat
famous he was like so concerned but he
learned very early on that like they're
really perfect for each other and he had
such nice things to say and he delivered
a beautiful prayer at the ceremony he
was like really touching like just
really encompassed like who he was who
their family was it was really beautiful
and then he told us he was like I'm also
gonna give one more before dinner I'm so
nervous
and he's like I'm also gonna say a
prayer for Lisa cuz she's going through
a hard time with the loss of her brother
and now her mom it was just like such a
sweet sentiment like a while' like
precious yeah he sounds like precious
gem of a man and we're about to eat and
he said the the prayer and I was sitting
at the table next to Lisa chef was at
the table next to me with Lisa
Vanderpump and Larry Birkhead and me and
Ben we're at the table right next to him
with Kyle Chad and a couple other so
yeah this guy he's an actor on the
Goldbergs oh yeah but I don't know I
don't watch that but what does he look
like he looks like a guy like other
people Adele younger tall or short is it
buried short no no he's someone the main
character oMG I'm gonna look it up
everyone's totally we're homies meeting
actors on the gold well I said am i
talking about the same on this no no as
I said do you know Sam Lerner cuz I'm
like we just met he was like yeah I was
like Coachella like whatever I was like
being when I was a Goldberg grouping so
wait so the dad is making the prayer
about like thank you Lord for this
beautiful day and then he said at the
very end like and also like a nod to
Lisa and her family we hope you give her
strength it was really sweet and I look
over at least said she was like not down
like at all and I'm not gonna take
credit for this because Ben said you saw
it and I didn't see it and Ben is not
the most well I've seen but he said he
saw her mouth so strange which was so if
true so rude and I wonder if they'll
edit that in keep that out like cuz they
were filming her as who they knew it was
coming
yeah that is so weird and what really
like annoys me I'm so glad that Lisa was
able to make it cuz like she's like such
an important figure in their lives but
like when she arrives like I like it
wasn't even looking on page six like
Lisa made it to the wedding like this is
a wedding of two like people they were
boss made it to the wedding great but
like who cares no it was like so
anticlimactic and I do have to say I
spent the entire weekend running away
from Lisa Vanderpump
not that I flatter myself at all to
think that she knows what the toast is
or what I've said about her over the
years but part of me thinks she's like
in tune with what goes on and she was
giving me like some of the dirtiest
looks ever or maybe I was just being
paranoid I don't know but like I that
guy was talking to my friend Sean and
like he knows Lisa very well and he
called this over and like I literally I
turned right around and I just turned
around like I just couldn't be there I'm
so afraid of her I would be [ __ ]
terrified okay so who'd you send the
most time with and I said but from the
cast I spend the most time with a kid
maloney cuz she's a real one and
actually Kristin Jodie and I have to say
I think Kristin Dodie might be one of
the most misunderstood people in the
world she was so kind to me in bed like
it's definitely awkward scenario like
you're like no but not everyone from the
wedding is coming from different parts
of the world it's like you're on their
terms it's like it's their show it was
their thing and so like I didn't want to
be too annoying or too thirsty like I
didn't show up to everything and I know
some of the cast members really well and
some of them not at all like I don't
know Haryana it all so I kind of like
stayed away from her cuz I'm also scared
of her and then I ran into her at the
wedding she let it could've been a nicer
kinder human being who was so beautiful
on the inside and outside and they just
like loved her now like it's just so
crazy I'm like you come up with these
conceptions of people in your head based
on like what you know about them from
Instagram and like it's just not real
you know it was a precious gem of a
woman so nice still kind to me and then
like introduced herself I was like oh my
god I love you like it's just so
interesting Chris and Dodie seemingly
crazy and she definitely is wild you
know but a nice girl and a beautiful
girl I'm like was so happy for Brittney
was crying the entire weekend like she's
stunning like just it's so funny what
you think you know and you don't you
know nothing Jon Snow
yeah you know that's hazy you also spend
a lot of time with Shep oh I mean it
spent the whole weekend with chef
because we were oh no girl boy with no
girl and we said the entire weekend
together because like we weren't a part
of the wedding party so we were like I
really left to fend for ourselves like
before Ben got there like me and Shep
had the night of our lives like we were
just running around Kentucky like drunk
and crazy and it was so fun like I
really had a great time with him um and
you know what when he gets drunk like he
tells stories and hears he's a talker
there's so boring like I literally
recorded this thing he was talking about
his grandma fainted on the dock like I
don't know it's great and the next
morning I'm like you have to watch the
city and he's like I can't like I know I
get like that he is the most boring
stories like ever and he was like listen
and I'm like I'm listening I'm just like
so bored by your stories he was like my
grandma fainted I'm like is she okay
that is so hard for you one to listen
and I was in bad oh my god yeah but we
just had a great time and then Ben came
and we were like three amigos you know
like running around town it was all just
like a really great weekend I was
enjoying like watching everything I
loved like come to life did it feel like
you were in an episode of Anaheim worlds
no because I wasn't like I was really
there drama um I don't know I don't know
I didn't ask I was just like happy to be
there and I don't want to be annoying it
Thursday and Brittney and Jax like are
just such a beautiful couple and Marga
will appreciate this like friends the TV
show was like so a part of their love
story yeah like it was in her vows she
was like you're my Lobster
when it when they introduced him as a
couple they introduced all the
bridesmaids and groomsmen first and they
played the friends theme songs that's
really cute and it's
Brittany was so much a part of like her
wedding planning you could tell like gee
what II like the song that they chose to
dance to or is it Shania Twain and right
Martina McBride it's still the one she
make my acquaintance just like such a
cute country song and then the message
of the song is like really so them and
like just after the wedding I was like I
believe in them like I really do like
and people writing me the nastiest sucky
messages like I give it a year like [ __ ]
you Sam from Africa like leave me alone
like I believe in them I believe in them
wholeheartedly yeah you know that's
amazing and I'm obsessed with the fact
that they took over Kentucky in a castle
oh my god Hey look my favorite rhymer
everybody knew they were the Jo and
Sophie of Kentucky like what was going
on Provence for Jo and so V was going on
in Kentucky like with paparazzi and like
fan yeah well the fandemonium was really
crazy because Kristin Dodie was like
really upset that there was like two
Crashers like there were people like
coming into the castle like being so
crazy and like there's phantom and then
there's just like blatant disrespect and
like going into the castle like taking
pictures of the venue like I was being
set up like just because everybody knew
where it was it's like people took
advantage and like it was really unfair
but it's actually really crazy I like
the Vanderpump kids are like rock stars
like we there was any like an engagement
like barbeque and everyone went and I
guess like the town found out that
everyone was there so by the time the
party was over at like 6 o'clock it was
still bright out like outside it was
like the way the Kardashians like they
leave their hotel and there's like
people that's what it was for the
Vanderpump they had barricades it was
crazy
that's crazy easy that's really cool it
was just a very I mean I had a great
time and I loved Jackson Britney and
like I was by the way Jackson sister is
just like such a scene like I just
[ __ ] love her is she's hosts her I
think she said she was like uh something
you know like I said Brittany's friends
are toasters Brittany's turns our
toasters between the feel cool like the
literally maid of honor you know yeah
but Jackson sister is so precious and
just like so beautiful and I was like I
was telling her is like I'm really
stopping to be here like I just feel
this weird way about Jax like I feel
like protective over him I'm like I just
love him and I think he's such a great
guy she was like he literally feels the
same way about you guys it's like I'm
like there's just listen meet you 11
like people were so confuse like how do
you know jack the Britney I'm like and
let me know Jack's Muse we both love
each other so much yeah
and I just I love them and I love him
Brittany and like I'm just I really
believe in them I believe in their love
and like I just I think that they're
gonna take it all the way I'm now more
than ever after watching them this
weekend like even more
cemented in the belief that like he has
changed man I'm cemented in the belief I
don't know if that was the right way of
saying it but now I am cement it's a
perfect way is hey okay well let's move
on to some more wedding news because joe
jonas and sophie turner are married
again by the way Jackson Britney Sophie
and Joe David Foster zoe kravitz zoe
kravitz i think there was one more
no it's four no okay so crazy so crazy
their wedding they got married at the
Chateau in Provence that we all know
inside and out from Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills it is so crazy it's like
they're not let more than one chateau
and Adam come on it's a beautiful
beautiful chateau we've gotten no
pictures like from them just at sea but
like from what I'm seeing is that like
Joe Jonas is the man of my dreams and
like if I wasn't so happy for somebody
Turner I would be so [ __ ] jealous
like I love him him and his dog and I
normally don't like a black tuxedo shirt
under a black jacket he looks so [ __ ]
handsome
him and his brother it's the Priyanka at
all like I [ __ ] Stan I [ __ ] Stan so
he Turner's the woman of my dreams so um
I'm just so happy like for then they
really are they are like such rock stars
he and I want to see more pictures I
want to get like inside I want to know
what it was like inside there me - I
need photos and look who was there Diplo
was there because he posted afterwards
but he said that they took his phone so
I'm so funny
so annoying um Ryan Tedder was there oh
he was yes of course Priyanka obviously
yeah hangout for their rehearsal dinner
everyone wore white and Joe and Sophie
wore red oh cool who from Game of
Thrones is where they're easy obviously
he surprised me and I need to know it
Jason Momoa like did double duty he
definitely did him because I don't think
him and so be Turner ever shot a scene
together in their lives and she was also
his family he was also like 11 when he
was on the show you know cuz he was on
so long ago she was like she was still
being a little [ __ ] with Lady ok say ok
say they don't know each other so well
but so many of the capital meant so many
cast members are going to Sophie's
wedding like he could see his friends at
Sophie's wedding it's like you know when
you like your friends came along did
they all go that's the question we don't
know like I didn't see anything just a
Jon Snow yeah I'm sure well he's out of
his descendants facilitate yeah yeah so
and they were close
ok also do you know Maisie Williams was
her maid of honor yes yes that is so
cute I'm trying to say so many videos I
like on refinery29 Facebook that I get
all the time like on my targeted
Facebook ads about like the budding
romance
between Maisie Williams and so Peter
about how like there I know I'd retire
best friends riders the day they were
born and well know nothing they were
born the day that they started working
together and Game of Thrones it's like
so cute and precious really cute Kofi's
what they call them really cute okay are
you ready for our next story no I want
to keep talking about Joe I love him
like honestly
we're probably gonna talk about it all
week his stuff will come out okay so
gently it's like devastated broken and
heart but like also really happy you
know also when they wore red they're her
southern Rose like red dress hi Junichi
wear high heels yes sir
tension work red dress red dress I wish
good I think she did too I think was on
purpose
it was definitely metaphor it was
definitely on purpose um [ __ ] what was I
gonna say oh do you see what he News is
doing where they like made a hashtag for
them Turner and Joe Jonas I thought it
was a real thing and then they're
commenting it on like their picture
they're trying to like curate the
hashtag they may know that's why I
really thought like the fandom did know
they made it up and they really caught
on cuz it was a good one but like
they're annoying no one it's like I
don't think they wanted what they're
like commenting on Joe and so he's like
pictures as couple hashtag Turner
intergenic so comes up in there in this
feat that's like really aggressive like
what if they didn't want a hashtag like
what if they didn't want to have like
this whole like who are like stop doing
things to the bride like there's enough
people to do that they don't need enews
like 20 year old associate who runs an
Instagram like making wedding decisions
for them yeah that's weird
hey Lloyd if like people like we're
asserting especially on social media I
got such a big platform like asserting
their branding on my wedding well I
doubt Joe and Sophie have noticed but
like if they did like they they can
delete it but I don't think they would
care I mean they're he used to like fans
and yeah you know fan accounts but I
just thought it was like an interesting
move yeah I don't know if they were used
to fan accounts with 20 million
followers it's like really aggressive
and like borderline intrusive
no totally I'm here for it okay next
story Kim Kardashian is rebranding her
shape our line kimono
supposed to Instagram this morning being
an entreprenuer and my own boss has been
one of the most rewarding challenges
I've been blessed with in my life what's
made it possible for me after all of
these years has been the direct line of
communication with my fans in the public
I am always listening learning and
growing I so appreciate the passion and
varied perspectives that people bring me
when I announce the name of my shaper
line I did so with the best intentions
in mind my brands and products are built
with inclusivity and diversity at their
core and after careful thought and
consideration I will be launching my
solution where brand under a new name I
will be in touch soon thank you for
always understanding and support always
so me and Margaret spoke about this on
our episode in the back of a car I hope
you listen to it it was really good at
audio quality and what we said was that
am I the person to like judge whether or
not kimono is offensive no I'm not
Japanese and I don't know really what
the meaning and the cultural like
background of it means but like I always
think about it ok let's say someone were
to do something with a Jewish word I'm
so thirsty I would've been like yes can
be gos yes but so while I don't
necessarily understand or agree with the
magnitude of but like how people came
for Kim like she never had bad
intentions and that's what I'm glad she
really addressed here but like I don't
know if you're gonna end up changing it
like why don't you just think it through
the first time yeah it's like a pretty
obvious reaction to do you yeah it's
like kimono it's like everyone knows
it's the Japanese word right and no the
problem that me and Margot said was that
everyone is all up in arms like talking
about is this cultural appropriation
when at the end of the day people should
be more open arms with the fact that it
makes no sense of kimonos like a type of
cardigan and she's making shorts well
here's the thing I think what was really
frustrating people is that if she if
this is successful which it will because
she's cam it's like people will start to
associate kimono with shapewear like a
kimono will start to be a [ __ ] a pair
of shorts a high powered panties right
and you're taking away from like the
culture culture in the history that's a
good point that III understand point I
actually did not expect her to do this
because I think they get flack all the
time right and they don't care or they
they they just do what they think is
best but I think it's like a big step
that she's changing it and I also and I
wasn't like totally sold on the name cuz
it doesn't make a lot of it's literally
making a line of hats and calling them
espadrilles like it makes a [ __ ] so
your name is like a race right your name
is hot
that's the SE yeah it makes no [ __ ]
sense and that's what I was up in arms
that like the lack of [ __ ] logical
ality of it all yeah so maybe we could
like brainstorm better names for her
because it's clear she doesn't have one
yet
yeah announce it it's like you have just
come up with like the word
there's just be called the Kim we're
yeah yeah like live
the less common is the best should be
k'kaw body oh yeah yeah but she has like
her fragrances that's cake is I'm just
annoyed because I really feel like her
making shapewear is like the move of the
century and I think it'll be huge for
her like this is what she should've been
doing all along instead of what she was
like making lighters so um I'm just
candles that LuAnn caught so much [ __ ]
for right I just like wish that like
this had went off better because now
everyone's talking about like the drama
around it that's and they're not talking
about like the sheer brilliance of this
business and how I will be purchasing
everything that they own
I know I'm still waiting for that body
makeup to come back I know I know it's
[ __ ] up yesterday my legs were like
Grandma purple and it was it was not
good I can't wait to make a video of my
before and after like I think my legs
are so crazy I think she would repost it
oh my god cuz you're like um I know I
know I know
Braille like with your purple veins no
and like when I'm cold like it's just
bad it's anyways I'm gonna make a whole
before and after video
I'm excited I'll help you produce it
thank you um oh also how critical of
Annie do you think it is to have Spanx
I'd only have one mic not at all okay
I feel like that was smart though nobody
better slim but launching the brand
around that one concept like isn't
groundbreaking especially cuz it's not
like the biggest solution to the world's
biggest problem but if it was a part of
just like a her catalogue of but she's
really like putting the brand on the
back of this idea and I don't think it's
like that life-changing but it is like a
smart thing that nobody's done
definitely like something every once in
a while people have a problem with but
um yeah I don't know how how critical it
is and like they can have to get both
actually no you could just flip it
around right
yes I'm sure it's reverse okay that's
good that's good cool well anyways I
love her and Joe but I just want
everything she does to be a huge success
and I appreciate this moment of
self-reflection and growth and doing
better Emma so I hope you come up with a
cool name this and final post lil nas X
comes out in pride oh I saw this and I
was so shocked and I just like loved the
subtlety of his message and I just think
like he's such a good role model I agree
lil nas X came out as a member of the
LGBT community in a world
on world Pride Day the rapper behind the
viral sensation Old Town Road told his
Twitter followers on Sunday to take a
close listen to his new song closure
what some of yall already know some of
y'all don't care some of y'all I'm not
gonna [ __ ] with me no more he tweeted
but before this month ends I want y'all
to listen to closure I just think like
it's such a simple like way of coming
out like some of you know some of you
don't you won't even care and some of
you or if I can have a fobs and you'll
hate me but whatever I love that and
it's very brave of someone to come out
like at their peak you know what I mean
it's so easy to like be brave when
nobody cares about you you know but like
when you're at the top billboard every
year crushin Taylor Swift number two
like and you use that moment to come out
like that's [ __ ] brave no totally and
I feel like in all these movies that you
see when someone's at the top of their
game it's always like their management
being like people won't like you started
silent yeah like people want you to be
like this people won't like you actually
I was you put out music like this and
I'm sure there were those kind of people
in his ear actually does that even
happen anymore because it does 2019 no
but it's definitely deaf by the status
of the world that's what I'm saying so
this is dope and I'm so happy for him me
too and just like I just really am I
love the message but I love the delivery
as well also did you see he posted a
picture of the album cover and he said
dead-ass I thought I made it obvious cuz
he's on his horse riding into a city in
one of the buildings is rainbow and he
like zooms in he's like I thought I made
it clear oh that's funny he's like not
sure he's trying me like the opposite of
tellers you have to be like overtly
obvious but and that wings so subtle
totally but it's like rainbows are the
pride pod but there's just like a
beautiful yeah great an array of color
it could have been just like an
inclination like yeah it could be
anything that's hilarious
this is also a great segue for us to
talk about pride yesterday oh my god yes
it was [ __ ] wild I'm like so worried
about the trash on the streets like it's
all I could think about last night now
oh my god but we spoke to the cops and
they said one that this was nothing
compared to New Year's Eve it's true but
to the Sanitation Department does pin it
up because I was wondering who cleans
this up like is it the cops
is it the DOE fund is it volunteers and
because the the parade was so delayed
like when we walked on 31st Street to
get to our flow there were people who
had been lined up for our it's like they
literally set up shop there so people
sleeping like they were they had their
entire days worth of trash there like
New Year's Eve it's just one night
yeah yeah and it's like confined to like
a few blocks but there was floats on
like how much different avenues
and they're just waiting there the
parade was delayed six hours so crazy
but it's like six hours worth of drinks
trash and pizza and heat and it rained
it was crazy it was a little
disappointing just because like its
first well it's New York pride like
we're New York let's go eat [ __ ]
together and more over than that it's
world pride like people from all around
the world came like like of all ages
like I saw so many people like from top
to bottom in wheelchairs and canes like
who just came because I thought it was
so important and I'm like you're gonna
make them stand for an extra six hours
like are you gonna and so there's no way
that every single float was able to go
because the we were there until about
9:00 the parade and we and our start
time was 5:30 nor forum was 4:30 oh was
it yeah and we've still hadn't actually
moved to the parade we were like waiting
in line to get to the parade but the
parade ends at 11 so like permits art
you can't parade after 11th streets have
to open so it was like all these there
are people who had start times at 10
o'clock like and they definitely did not
get to go and it's like companies big
and small like organizations who like
raise the money to like buy the phone
it's expensive like it's really sad
actually like it was I wish that they
would have cared more like I did pride
three years ago and there was a two hour
delay and I was like are you like it
sucks but like that's just the way all
parades nothing's perfect and a two-hour
July seems reasonable to me
but like going on a six-hour delay like
that that sucks especially when people
who came from all over paid a lot of
money might not even be able to end up
going on their float like that sucks
yeah and I just I don't know who to
point the finger and point blame out you
know I'm I'm tempted to point it towards
de Blasio because when it when in doubt
de Blasio out yeah yeah Shepherd for
mayor but we can't blame them for things
that he has done or else it takes away
from our that's true and things happen
all the time in the city and and they
happen and I'm sure there's delays but
like this was on another scale and it
was clear whoever organized it like did
not did not prepare it was like fire
festival yes I mean like loving this
quote that I just made a plug I want to
get business cards and like just hand
them out like I'm running for mayor how
old you be frame
probably like 35 I don't know but your
next big opportunity's coming and I
think mine is to I think I should
actually run for mayor all it takes to
feel like you're ready to own the now is
$10 so I'm gonna get business card made
up obviously from mister Franca's that's
where all the finest except for yours
all the finest business cards come from
and what was it thank you when in doubt
de Blasio
out they gave me the creative freedom to
like make my own fucked-up business card
yeah I appreciate that like no judgment
they were like you do you if you own a
brothel your [ __ ] Penelope's awesome
we're gonna make you a business card mr.
Brittain you can create a truly
professional unique card in minutes
upload your own design or start with one
of their professionally designed options
which is what exactly what Jackie should
have done Vistaprint offers simple tools
and a wide range of templates to choose
from pick the paper stock the style and
the quantity that's right for you this
different wants you to be able to own
the now in any situation which is why
our listeners will get 500 high-quality
custom business cards starting at $9.99
use code toast at vistaprint.com
that's code toast TOA st at
vistaprint.com toast at Vistaprint calm
on the know guys when in doubt DeBlasio
out totally a little good slogan same I
got like save my life so you did not
watch Kardashians correct no but wait I
still wanna talk about it right because
one I don't know the reason for the
delay yet and I haven't read my morning
paper so I'm hoping that the New York
Times will spell it out for me I'm sorry
the New York Post I don't they're fun to
say she's small totally script I can but
the TPG float was incredible oh and oh
my gosh you're on episode it is up I
worked in OT last night to get it up
before midnight so we did a get ready
with us slash behind the scenes of us at
pride and it was so fun and like we were
on 31st Street for four and a half hours
530 first Street was it like it was a
[ __ ] parade it was so got Inlet we
have pizza we had wine we had a float we
had TPG with pink hair we had music we
had Lady Bunny on the ones and - oh yeah
Lady Bunny who by the way I like love
because she respects the hell out of
Taylor Swift and I was just like like
watching her from afar cuz she's like
truly iconic no truly iconic she played
the best music yes she did yeah and the
great catalog so while we were on 31st
she like I felt like we were in the only
thing we didn't have was like people in
the stands like actually people were
sitting at restaurants watching us on
the float but like we were parading on
the float on 31st Street right we could
have been down it's done well I wouldn't
have known the difference because we
were so lit up 31st Street right and
just the TVG float we flew a colony
Airlines we flew equality Airlines to
Fiji put so much effort into the flow
like I loves the details by far the
nicest lot I saw for a 10-block radius
like it was really well done and it had
a [ __ ] roof so we were not in the Sun
like that I was so worried before no so
great
before it was likely nice eeny prideful
and that's a word right cried folio full
of pride yeah great
I'm prayerful and it was it was really
fun day and even though it didn't pan
out the way that we had all hoped you
know we weren't the only ones like
plenty of PDA was so crazy it's like
when we left to the parade like six
hours later I would have to walk a
couple blocks to get to like where you
could get a cab and we were walking down
blocks of people who were waiting and
like what you would think like by the
end of the day it's like the
lesser-known small brands Johnson to
Johnson was there I don't think they
ever made it know and honored way across
honor block was bumble hmm uh Barry's
bootcamp like some visiting their
society visiting nurses I'll it flow
they had a whip flow they're the most
premium drug minds I've ever seen in my
life no totally and they played Ashley
oh right didn't kind bar to yeah so like
so many floats so many people and when
we were walking there were like we were
two box away and there were still floats
and I just think wanted to tell these
people like you're never gonna make it I
just like I'm thinking about those
people today like I hope I hope they
made it legs are for everyone people
came from out of town yeah to March and
like spent a lot of money cuz it like
was important to them yeah that's [ __ ]
like what's sad and so like if New York
City can't handle world pride then like
don't volunteer I don't know anymore
you know maybe not handle it so like I
really want to blame our city but I
don't know that if it if it was the
city's fault I know if they could pull
off Times Square New Year's Eve like I
think they can pull off pretty much pull
up the Puerto Rican Day Parade they pull
up at the Israeli Day Parade they you
have parades all the time that's true
but I think this is like the biggest
yeah there was millions I think they
literally didn't say no to anyone who
wanted to float which is great because
it's like you should include anyone who
wants to be a part of it but at some
point would just accept account for
something right and we could consolidate
we could have teamed up with Barry's I
don't actually know our slowest popping
but like Barry's and bumble Cup team
yeah that's a perfect match
yeah but this like skinny people
together totally maybe they'll date so I
just watch Keeping Up with the
Kardashians but Jackie did not so you
watch it today and then we're recording
our final episode of the week tonight
for tomorrow morning so we'll recap
Kardashian's then yeah tomorrow will be
podcast only you will get everything
that you need before you head out into
the holiday weekend I'm so excited for
the holiday weekend I was saying to
Claudia yes I'm so excited for holiday I
need a holiday
I'm so excited to come it's the toasters
tea early but not while I'm just
partying it up in the Hamptons I need a
holiday and I mean like not getting one
from your holiday plans I got my
different my holiday plans like a hat
I'm gonna be in the city for the 4th and
then it's Friday I can rock them to go
away after the fourth cuz then it's just
to the weekend it's Friday to Sunday not
long enough
right I'll be here sweltering like HM yo
maybe I'll do a tutorial or something ok
maybe I'll get some work done
maybe use it as like a platform for
productivity right but it's like hard
for me to get work time unlike no one's
around there's only so many things that
I like you know what I mean yeah so
we'll see but anyways they never know oh
in case you're wondering the women of
New York one had a scheduling conflict
there they postponed they'll probably be
on after the holiday okay mom but just
today no longer work for them because
there's there's so many of them yeah so
we're trying to get as many as we can
yes we are because they're there cause
is an important one and one that we can
get by I told them that we could fit up
to four people so we'll work on it yeah
thank you guys so much for listening
what a crazy day if this is your first
time listening welcome to the morning
toast we go live Monday through Friday
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on YouTube so
for your YouTube gal subscribe this like
it we do a videos many a time a week but
if you're more of a commuter you like to
listen to podcasts the morning shows is
available as a podcast as well on iTunes
in the Apple podcast storage to search
the morning toast we're also available
on Spotify on stitcher I Heart Radio
Public Radio anywhere you can listen to
podcasts so subscribe over there tell a
friend tell your mom new episode of the
schvitz comes out tomorrow and that's
all we got we'll see you guys in a
podcast only episode tomorrow morning
and check out our newest patron episode
patreon.com slash the morning toast you
have such a friend that pride episode in
the other podcast episodes we're premium
if you need something for your road trip
yes head over there for conspiracy
theories on how Chris Klein is story
Cruz's dad
you